[Music]
Akeem never at a man before what about
your father
I had no father I was brought to life
baby oh that's neat
[ __ ]
[Music]
who's this woman
Wonder Woman is there anything else you
enjoy and war-ravaged the earth the gods
created us
I go five so though you cannot fight for
them
Wonder Woman what
where the pg13 experience at an IMAX 3d
hey youtubers is Charlie so there's all
kinds of wonder woman drop in so we got
to talk about her powers her role is a
demigod like a full-blown demigod versus
her other origin stories her abilities
in the DC EU because it looks like she
is full-blown flying in this TV spot
isn't because geoff johns is teasing
that he's already writing the titans TV
show he tweeted out this picture and
it's the cover from his run on Teen
Titans back in 2003 so it implies a
little bit about the light up so I'll
explain who Wonder Girl is in the
difference between Donna Troy and cassie
sandsmark because there's two different
versions of the character and they have
kind of a funny origin story but there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so we got confirmation on
final boss form Aries in this version of
the trailer here so you can kind of see
his horn from his helmet sticking around
as he is going at her dual wielding and
she's blocking it with her gauntlets so
what it looks like it's happening is
when she's absorbing all this damage
from this super weapon as it goes off it
really does look like she's flying in
this sequence here and stops them from
doing whatever it is they're trying to
do then she throws down with final boss
for Mary's because he's so pissed that
she stopped him from achieving his goal
what does he sound like what does his
face look like I have a feeling did you
know just guessing that they're going
with a relatively injustice look and you
won't see too much of his actual face
underneath the helmet you didn't see
glowing eyes that'll make him seem even
more powerful so they want to make boss
form Aries feel as inhuman as possible
the power of a god so the best way to do
that would be to not give him a face at
all just making these glowing eyes we
need this really terrifying helmet but
if you're wondering about the dual
wielding he just dual wields inside the
injustice comic book so that's probably
why he's doing welding here but what
about her powers though so they really
got juiced up Silver Age in post-crisis
if you don't know what crisis is it's
crisis on Infinite Earths it happened in
the mid 80s it was the big event in
comics that marked the end of the Silver
Age in the beginning of the modern age
of comics so everybody's back stories
got reckoned in modern age Wonder Woman
basically became a female version of
Superman in terms of her powers and
abilities she could fly she was
much indestructible and she even got to
carry that sword and shield around so
the big difference between her and
Superman though is that she was a
full-blown warrior so she became more of
a punch stabbed first person than
Superman who tried to work through his
problems before he crushed them into
soda cans but the first time that she
did anything close to Flag was during
the Silver Age where they said glide on
air currents so it's not like full-blown
flying but then post-crisis it was just
full-blown flying initially the ability
to fly was granted by the god Hermes
then during the new 52 she could fly on
her own in the line between Superman and
Wonder Woman powers got even fuzzier so
I think what the movie universe is doing
is just differentiating Superman and
Wonder Woman so based on the camera
tricks they're pulling here in the way
they're speeding up and slowing down
footage it really does look like she's
gliding on air currents Silver Age style
so it's way more than jumping but it's
not quite full-blown flying so they
haven't done a great job of explaining
it but I think the idea is is that
Superman is the only true God on earth
in terms of his power levels and
abilities but Wonder Woman is really
close but the only way she's going to
get the upper hand on him is if she has
her sword which can pierce Doomsday's
skin and she has her gauntlets so it's a
lot of fun to try and figure out what
everyone's power levels and abilities
are so let me know how powerful do you
think that Wonder Woman is just based on
the footage that they've showed us in
the half tease that Superman will get
his true birth as the hero of the DCE
you during the Justice League movie but
they were very cryptic about the way
they said that like okay there's going
to be some sort of Superman rebirth in
some way they say that the Superman
we've seen before is not the true
version of Superman that he's destined
to become so it's not like it's going to
be a physical different version of
Superman it's just that he hasn't
achieved the greatness that he will
achieve during the Justice League movie
so hopefully that gets you more excited
about Superman dominating during the
Justice League movie but the Titans TV
show Geoff Johns is teasing that he's
already writing it this is the best
thing ever I'm not expecting the
episodes to actually drop to like fall
2018 because he's literally just writing
the pilot right now it's going to take
him a long time to get it going but the
way he's doing this is teasing the
roster when he wrote it
it was the cassie sandsmark
version of Wonder Girl not the Donna
Troy version so if you saw the animated
movie that they just dropped they tease
that Donna Troy is joining the team
wearing this version of the costume so
everyone's like yay we're finally
getting Donna Troy we're finally getting
Wonder Girl part of the Teen Titans so
as you can imagine Donna Troy Wonder
Girl is kind of like a junior version of
Wonder Woman who was initially created
because of the comics code Authority and
people thought that they were corrupting
youth with the way that Wonder Woman's
costume look so they needed a version of
the character that looked less sexy and
she was introduced during the first Teen
Titans comic book way back in the 60s
the Junior Justice League is what they
called them and they ended up having to
change her backstory so many times it
got super messy she ended up being this
duplicate of Wonder Woman then she was
her sister then she was secretly the
daughter of a normal family there was
this big story arc that Marv Wolfman
wrote during the classic Teen Titans run
called who is Donna Troy where Robin
goes around very literally piecing
together her origin story who the hell
is this character during the Young
Justice Teen Titans graduation day
crossover she was killed off leaving the
door open for the cassie sandsmark
version of Wonder Girl to come join the
Teen Titans but it was another way to
just do a very young version of Wonder
Woman they called her Wonder Girl they
changed her backstory a couple times to
initially she's the daughter of an
archaeologist they find these artifacts
that used to be used by Wonder Woman in
those give her her powers then during
the new 52 they make her a little more
Street tough and she steals some
artifacts from a museum those artifacts
give her her powers she's not quite as
powerful as Wonder Woman during the new
52 she had like a version of a lot of
those powers that would manifest as very
special invisible armor she had a red
version of the lasso but as of rebirth
Donna Troy is now a member of the Titans
team there is no cassie sandsmark so
right now in the comics there is nobody
that's called Wonder Girl but you have
to remember that Jeff John said there be
a couple differences he did confirm
Beast Boy he may have also confirm
Starfire but remains to be seen what
they're going to do with Wonder Girl if
it's going to be his version of Kathy or
if it's going to be Donna Troy or if
they're not going to do her at all
but I think part of the idea with the
Titans TV show is
do not duplicate powers so everybody
that they do on the team will have very
different functions very different
abilities so I'm not expecting everybody
from the comics and they haven't said
anything about what's going on with
Superboy but I think if there's any
chance for any of the DC TV shows to do
Superboy it would be the Titans TV show
and we haven't got any confirmation on
which version of Wally West they're
going to do but I will be doing another
flash video later today I'll talk a
little bit more about wally west and his
future on that TV show whenever i post
that so that should post in a little
while but i'll say congratulations to
israel thule no UND in just is to give
away please private message me so I can
get your contact details you can click
here for brand new flash footage and you
can click here for my non-spoilery
guardians of the galaxy to review thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you